e l'élection en géorgie bon on peut la
suivre à la télé est par contre la vraie
manifestation est là le vrai événement
ça va être le 6 janvier à washington
donc on change nos plans on prend un vol
pour arriver à baltimore situent tous
les vols étaient complets donc là déjà
on comprend qu'il ya quelque chose parce
que tous les vols pour washington
complet c'est pas anodin dans le val
pour baltimore on voit de plus en plus
de casse tête rouge qui dépassent des
sièges donc là encore une fois on se dit
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
viennent et puis on arrive dans
washington le 5 au soir toutes les rues
sont vides parce que y'a le confinement
sauf tous les supporters de trump qui
sont là devant les hôtels qui sont tous
complets sur les groupes whatsapp où
nous on est pour travailler parce que
pour travailler en tant que journaliste
on est sur les groupes whatsapp des
supporters de trump on voit que les
supporters de trump arrivent de partout
de californie d'eutelsat du wyoming de
de vraiment de tout le pays le lendemain
matin on a la mine on va la
manifestation celle du matin que tout le
monde connaît trump et son discours et
le reste appartient à l'histoire
du coup quand vous arrivez sur place le
matin trump et son discours est ce que
la déjà on sent une effervescence est ce
qu'on sent déjà préparés ou est ce que
c'est de l'opportunisme qui sait ce qui
s'est déroulé après il ya un narratif
très guerrier qui a voulu être racontée
immédiatement après les les modes du du
capital et y ait réellement fausse le 6
janvier au matin il ya beaucoup de gens
ils sont tous très énervé mais il suffit
d'avoir déjà été un rallye de trump pour
savoir que c'est il ya rien de plus
normal ce qui se passe le 6 janvier au
matin ce que trump dit ce qu'on a
souligné ce qui indique qu'
effectivement et des choses très graves
et très
allongée capitale il faut y aller soyez
un héros et par 06 et s'avança c'est son
fils mais bon mais en fait trump dit des
choses comme ça depuis depuis six ans
dont on fête le 6 janvier au matin car
rien de différent fondamentalement à
part qu'il a perdu les élections
d'ailleurs quand il dit allez-y marchait
sur le capitole je vais venir à vélo où
il va et vient pas avec gimont dans une
voiture il s'en va
s'il y avait une volonté de coup d'état
pourquoi cette foule aurait d'abord pris
le temps d'aller sur la pelouse de
l'ellipse pendant six heures parce que
ils sont rassemblés très tôt le matin le
d'histoire est arrivé tard l'émeute du
capital elle commence réellement aux
alentours de 13 heures donc non c'est
parce que en fait effectivement les
supporters de trump on le sait ce sont
des jusqu'au boutistes
à la turquie on sait de ce tempérament
assez viriliste de dire on va on va vous
mettre dehors nous on est des patriotes
nous on est des américains il arrive au
pied du capitole et encore une fois ce
qui s'est passé on connaît après donc
toi à la fin du discours tu vas tu vas
suivre le mouvement on va dire de même
pas en fait à la fin du discours je vais
manger je vais manger et c'est véridique
on est avec plusieurs journalistes dont
il ya brain starten de photojournalistes
qui travaille avec avec moi et il ya
d'autres journalistes internationaux qui
sont là et on va manger un sandwich pas
très loin de la maison blanche et on se
regarde et rosie la journée est terminée
et où on se re dirige quand même vers la
pelouse pour voir ce qui se passe là on
voit que toute la foule est massée au
capital donc on y va et en fait on est
arrivé à peu près au même moment où les
premières barrières ont commencé à
tomber et ben là on s'est dit que
finalement la journée n'est pas finie et
que ça allait durer pour un petit moment
j'attends du coup à ce moment là toi tu
arrives tu trahis est donc le avec le
fauteuil motorisé par brain certaines
vous commencez du poids à suivre un
groupe non ne suis pas de groupes déjà
on est séparés parce que immédiatement
on comprend que les images et même le
ressenti
c'est au plus près des barricades donc
déjà en fait on sent la foule pour se
retrouver vraiment là où ben t'as pris
les photos et/ou moi j'ai pris les
idéaux que j'ai pu publier sur twitter
en même temps dont déjà on est très
rapidement séparés je le saurai à la fin
de la journée mais en fait brent et moi
à des moments différents on s'est pris
des jets de spray au poivre au même
titre que les manifestants donc ça nous
arrange capacités pendant pas mal de
temps et puis après deux façons c'était
impossible de se retrouver alors la
petite histoire c'est que on s'est quand
même retrouvé par pur hasard à
l'intérieur du capital au même endroit
mais maintenant on a on n'a pas suivi de
groupe en fait il n'y avait pas de
groupe il y avait un groupe qui était
cette foule
complètement compath mais qui était
presque une et indivisible quoi est-ce
qu'on peut rappeler quand même j'ai dû
les questions sur sa sur la le contexte
sur pourquoi en fait les manifestants
c'était important pour eux d'aller au
capitole alors le contexte il est simple
c'est que en eau fin novembre joe biden
remporte les élections aux yeux de tous
sauf que une personne de donald trump
donald trump conteste cette élection en
boucle en boucle en boucle il va même
jusqu'à appeler le gouverneur de géorgie
là où on était précédemment poursuivre
les et les élections du sénat pour lui
dire trouve moi tant de vote pour que je
puisse gagner les élections enfin l'état
donc on était vraiment un moment de fin
vraiment de polarisation du pays
complètement d'inde et en fait je
voulais aller au capital parce que il
voulait interrompre la validation des
élections présidentielles par le
parlement qui était en train de se
dérouler et qui a été donc interrompu
par l'invasion et qui a repris
immédiatement pratiquement après que les
manifestants soient a été évacué
d'accord
donc toi tu arrives en bas du bas des
marches du capitole tu va monter petit à
petit avec les manifestants c'est comme
ça que ça se passe et comment tu vas
réussir à rentrer dedans finalement par
la porte non mais vraiment c'est à dire
que fait ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre c'est que et ça a
été prouvé d'ailleurs depuis c'est à
dire que le 7 janvier tout le monde crie
au coup d'état ourdi par des groupes
extrêmes d'extrême droite des
suprémacistes blancs les brad boyes les
au skipper
il était là mais c'était une extrême
minorité des gens qui étaient là
les gens sont arrivés ils se sont
retrouvés face à un cordon de sécurité
mais qui était cruellement lacunaire
mais cruellement latuner avec des yeux
de français et de parisiens qui a vu les
gilets jaunes les manifestations à nuit
debout qui a même vu la zad et c'est le
fin le cordon de sécurité quand on
arrive au devant de capital mais il est
enfin il fait rire il ya des policiers
déjà qu'ils sont en sous nombre pas
équipés ils ont pas de case qui n'ont
pas de lunettes ils ont analysé ils ont
des petits spray au poivre qui sont face
à
plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes au bas
mot et qui le pousse pousse pousse
pousse pousse honnêtement moi je
n'arrête pas de manière tacite et les
gens qui sont morts pendant ces jeunes
je n'arrête pas de me dire depuis un an
que mais ça aurait pu être tellement
pire tellement pierre lui c'est parce
que là on voit sur des sur des sur des
images sur ce qui s'est passé sur les
gens qui sont rentrés je sais pas si on
peut mettre d'ailleurs tu étais image
que tu as films et photos qu'il a des
gens qui sont passés et atteste que toi
tout de suite tu t'es dit là ça va
vraiment pété quoi sachant que mais
c'est ça qui est la dichotomie assez
incroyable c'est à dire qu on est après
george clooney on est après les émeutes
de black eyes matters on est aux états
unis un pays où l'utilisation des armes
à feu par la police on va dire est
nettement plus la tis qu'en france
mais du point de vue des policiers du
point de vue des manifestants
j'ai trouvé en fait encore une fois d'un
point de vue français mais que ça aurait
pu être mais tellement pire
moi j'ai vu dans les couloirs du
capitole des flics qui étaient isolés
j'étais tout seul en qu'elles les
manifestantes n'ont pas touché à un
cheveu alors il ya eu il ya eu
effectivement ce policier qui a été
traînée en dehors d'une des entrées
qu'on voit en photo qui a témoigné la
sur arte récemment je crois qu'ils
s'appellent l'officier fans
effectivement ce qui lui arrive est
absolument gravissime mais c'était un
moment de la journée où je pense qu'il
ne restait plus que des groupes
extrémistes très très violente qui
s'était cristallisée autour de la
dernière rentrée où il y avait un
affrontement et qui eux pour le coup
était très clairement là pour rester à
mes fans homme a été évacué par des
manifestants c'est ce qu'il raconte dans
un documentaire c'est quand même élan il
ya des gens qui sont mis autour de lui
pour le protéger pendant qu est ce qu
ils sont même battus contre des gens ont
essayé de le lyncher dans cette foule
était très comment dire hétérogènes
quant à ce qu'elle voulait ah bah elle
était entièrement et complètement
hétérogène encore une fois il ya eu 7
120 arrestations sur depuis un an 720
arrestation sur ces 7 120 arrestations
89% des individus interpellés on est à
près de 90 % ne sont pas affiliés ni de
près ni de loin à un groupe
suprémacistes blancs d'extrême droite
etc c'est des gens qui ont l'âge moyen
est de 40 ans c'est très vieux pour des
manifestations d'extrême droite
y a que 9 % de ces interpellés qui sont
au chômage c'est très très bas 25 %
d'entre eux ont un collège universitaire
c'est très très haut encore une fois
quand on regarde les statistiques qui
ont été faits par des universitaires
américains sur les arrestations de ses
720 personnes si on considère donc que
logiquement ça représente la foule qui
était là et la foule la plus vieille
valise et vu que ça a fait pas ses 720
arrestation de gentils ont vraiment été
dans le capital et on fait des commis
des choses réponse
ça ne représente absolument pas là la
typologie et la démographie des
individus qui prennent normalement pas à
des manifestations d'extrême droite aux
états unis et qui
et qui participa les affrontements est
ce que toi en tant qu' en tant que média
tu as été inquiété où tu as vu des
collègues être inquiété parce qu'on sait
que dans dans ses meetings là c'est
assez compliqué de travailler et alors
c'est là où parlons là c'est mon
expérience personnelle qui témoigne en
rien de l'entièreté de l'événement moi à
part à la fin de la journée ou
je me suis fais moi même pas agresser
mais où des profs boys ont pris mon
téléphone et ils ont cassé parce que je
les filme mais je me rendais pas compte
de ce que je suis mais c'est une autre
histoire ni moi ni brent certaine dans
la journée on a été entier t par les
manifestants moi les manifestants mon
bébé c'est à dire à un moment je me suis
pris un jet de peppers prêt et j'ai une
femme qui m'a filé des lingettes
démaquillantes pour pouvoir me
débarrasser j'ai été évacué vers
l'arrière et c'est par des gens qui en
fait je pensais que j'étais avec eux et
c'est donc non après j'ai vu que
notamment les télés qui était en
périphérie mais là je pense que c'est on
peut faire un parallèle avec les
manifestations en france je pense que
quand on est un rédacteur d'un journal
on est beaucoup moins identifiables et
identifié que des chaînes de télé qui
était en périphérie qui elles se sont
fait casser leur matériel il ya eu il ya
eu des journalistes agressés
moi j'ai vu une consoeur de la fp
notamment au tout début
des gens lui faisait des remarques voilà
moi j'ai pas vu de l'agression en tant
que telle entre toujours tout que les
autorités étaient postés vers le
capitole pour faire des plateaux jeux
plus facile toi tu l'as vu et du coup
j'étais directement sur le passage
finalement de la manifestation ah bah
oui alors il ya eu eux et puis il ya eu
les journées c'était à l'intérieur du
capitole pour couvrir le le vote scrutin
et alors j'imagine que pour eux
l'événement a été autrement plus
traumatisant parce que ils étaient
enfermés dans l'hérault dans l'est dans
les chambres avec des portes fermées en
fait il ne voyait pas vraiment ce qui se
passait et pour eux ça a dû être
réellement traumatisante on se rappelle
de l'image du policier qui met ce qui
pointe son arme vers l'extérieur les les
les sénateurs et les députés qui avaient
des masques à gaz un peu fait maison sur
place effectivement c'est c'était assez
compliqué à l'intérieur
est ce que toi du coup tu vois ces gens
de
devenir de deux endroits différents est
ce que tu te dis une fois dedans ça va
ça va se calmer ou alors ils avaient un
but très précis où il n'avait pas de
buts c'est ça c'est pour ça que safran
ça voulait rien dire presque leurs trucs
et on voyait s'était pas préparé serre
que encore une fois bon alors
effectivement il y en a qui sont rentrés
en disant on va chercher nancy pelosi on
va chercher les yeux je pense
qu'effectivement il serait tombé sur 26
pelosi ou sur
mike pence le vice-président républicain
au vice-président de donald trump y
étaient à l'intérieur à ce moment là je
pense que là effectivement ça aura été
ça aurait été potentiellement très
dangereux pour ces gens là moi ce qui
m'a marqué c'est une fois de ces gens
rentrent à l'intérieur du capital
ils se comportent comme des touristes
c'est à dire que quand ils rentrent dans
la grande rotonde il ya quand même des
toiles qui sont accrochées dans cette
rotonde dans la petite retombe ya des
statuts et des vitrines avec des objets
exposés à l'intérieur
moi j'ai pas vu de tags j'ai pas vu
dégradation j'ai pas vu en france encore
une fois un endroit comme ça une
l'assemblée nationale serait envahi
pendant une manifestation gilet jaune on
sait très bien ce qui se passerait on
l'a vu à l'arbre de 13 heures
ce qui était assez incroyable encore une
fois c'est de mon point de vue et d'un
point de vue je pense très français
c'est que les gens en fait là bas
était contre le gouvernement mais d'une
certaine manière en fait d'ailleurs il y
en avait qui étaient habillés en
habit d y en avait qui étaient déguisées
en george washington etc qui en fait
révère le drapeau révère l'amérique en
tant que nation en tant que symbole est
là était contre un gouvernement donc en
fait une fois qu'ils étaient à
l'intérieur qu'ils avaient pris leurs
photos et qu'ils avaient fait leur show
à l'américaine quand la garde nationale
est arrivé là moi je me suis dit soit sa
part en cacahuète et là ça peut partir
très très loin et on pas du tout mais il
ya la vidéo d'ailleurs sur twitter que
j'ai posté la garde nationale arrive les
gens s'en vont il sort tranquillement
par la porte ils sortent ils hurlent ils
font mais on a arrêté le vote ils
comprennent pas du tout dans deux heures
le vote reprend une saison rien arrêté
du tout
mais voilà ils sortent et ce qui est
d'ailleurs la preuve que s'il y avait eu
une dissuasion réel dès le départ mais
jamais ces gens seraient allés jusque là
c'était pas des manifestants qui étaient
prêts à vraiment en découdre n'hésitez
pas prêt à être sur place finalement
mais c'était même pas prêts à franchir
la porte ouais mais en fait c'est on a
l'impression comme sale c'est quelque
chose de très près pareil mais en fait
le seul ressort de leur action a été
l'impunité dont ils ont profité une
impunité qui est mais qui a été prouvé
en par des enquêtes sur le
dysfonctionnement de la police qui
arrivait de faire la police
je sais plus laquelle qui garde
républicaine qui arrive très très tard
fiable la garde républicaine qui arrive
très tard et puis qui arrive après il ya
eu il ya eu des forces de police de
virginie son arrivée qui ont déjà pu
réussir un peu à contenir qui était un
peu mieux équipés mais
il faut savoir aux izards est il
arrivait dans un dans un bâtiment qui
était plus à défendre c'était un
bâtiment qui était va tuer moi j'ai vu
des policiers arrivés de constitution
avenue des avenues périphériques haut
qui ne pouvait pas rejoindre leurs
confrères à l'intérieur alors que là il
ya un terrain parce qu'ils étaient
coupées par part beaucoup de
manifestants et c'est surtout par les
médias du monde entier donc là
l'équation elle est assez simple c'est à
dire que s'il ya le moindre gramme déjà
que c'était la journée de même été un
drame haye avait il n'y avait rien de
contrôlable dans cette journée il ya eu
des rares à rien de contrôler si ce
n'est l'évacuation ou là pour le coup
des forces de l'ordre ont fait un boulot
assez propre parce que justement ce qui
est assez marquant mais c'est vrai que
on comprendra que ce que tu racontes
c'est qu'en fait une fois que la police
arrive en grand nombre et qu'ils sont là
et qu'ils disent aux gens on va dire il
siffle la fin de la récréation et ben
ali les gens qui sont là disent bah oui
pardon on s'en va on a bien profité oui
là la plupart est alors après encore une
fois il y en a cristallisé alors autour
de cette entrée où il ya les photos pas
celle là qui est en train de passer à
l'écran mais l'autre
c'est celle entre étiez donc du côté de
l'obélisque et ses amis au centre
où il ya ces images où l'officier fans
ce fait se fait molester est traînée ou
là il ya une vraie violence et il ya un
vrai affrontement très il ya un policer
dix ans avec une arme à feu pour les
faire dégager de stars mais même là
enfin il ya des gens il ya une batte de
baseball il ya un ou deux casques une
eau de lunettes il ya un mec qui a un
pied de table avec un clou qui dépasse
mais en fait c'est rien c'est à dire que
on sait comment des manifestants et
notamment des groupuscules peuvent venir
ultra préparé même en termes de
matériels à des manifestations surtout
surtout aux états unis les gersoises
états unis parce que voilà second
amendement quand même c'est pas rien
enfin encore une fois mais on a ça ça a
été très très très très soft par rapport
à ce qui aurait pu arriver et ce qui
arrive pratiquement mais tous les mois
aux etats-unis dans d'autres
manifestations est-ce que tu comprends
quand même que cette ces images peuvent
complètement choqué le monde entier il
ya sur le coup beaucoup de gens
extérieurs voit ça et se disent à la le
capitole et a été attaqué mais en fait
tout ce que je dis n'enlève rien au
caractère déjà illégal quasi terroristes
de l'acte
encore une fois
les images ont débarqué sur les écrans
télé moi ce que je en tant que personne
n'était là bas est encore une fois en
basant sur les études qui ont été faites
depuis un an que j'ai suivi parce que ça
m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
il ya eu un narratif d'immédiatement
tiré parce qu'on était à la fin du
mandat trump parce qu'il ya une
cristallisation autour des questions
raciale aux états unis évidente il ya eu
un narratif qui a immédiatement été
écrit en mode c'est un coup d'état ourdi
par les groupuscules extrême d'extrême
droite etc encore une fois c'est faux et
ça ne veut pas dire que ces groupuscules
ne sont pas dangereux ils le sont et cet
événement les a je pense mais
complètement d'albanese et je pense
qu'ils les maîtres se disent bas alors
on peut mettre un pays à genoux si on en
veut
encore une fois
on est sur une sur les 720 arrestation
on est sur 90 % qui n'ont aucune
affiliation à des groupes d'extrême
droite on est sur pratiquement plus d'un
tiers qui vient de zones urbaines ou
périurbaines c'est à dire ils viennent
pas des red state de la ruralité etc ils
viennent de californie camatchy babbitt
la femme qui a été tuée par un voilà ils
viennent de san diego ils viennent des
banlieues de ces du t2 saas etc c'est
des gens qui ont 25% sur un diplôme
universitaire dont on n'est pas sûr des
gens pas éduqué etc
moyenne d'âge de 40 ans
enfin il ya tout un seulement voilà
intéressant seulement 30% avait avait un
casier judiciaire donc sur les 720
arrêté 30 % ou un casier judiciaire
avaient des casiers judiciaires pour des
petits délits détention de marijuana et
cette vitesse mach un terrain dans les
manifestations d'extrême droite
normalement aux états unis se chiffrer à
64 % la moyenne aux états unis sur les
gens qui ont un casier judiciaire entre
10 mai un passé ses rangs pour cent donc
on n'est jamais en fait sur plein de
choses on n'est pas éloigné de la
moyenne de ce que représentent les
américains aujourd'hui et c'est juste ça
c'est de dire que cette manifestation
elle a été avant tout
elle a été avant tout la démonstration
d'une nouvelle colère aux états unis que
encore pratiquer cinq ans après
l'édition de donald trump on a encore
beaucoup de mal à
à palper je trouve dans ce pays mais
qu'on arrive à comprendre
une nouvelle manifestation comme ça si
les éléments sont comment dire à nouveau
réunis pourraient nouveaux arrivés aux
états unis obama avait dévoilé beaucoup
de cratères
et du coup à la fin donc tout le monde
disait la garde républicaine arrive des
manifestants partent et devant le
capitole toi toi tu vas être toi tu vas
être devant le capitole tu vas y rester
un petit moment encore moins on reste
jusqu'au bout on reste jusqu'à ce que le
cordon de de sécurité en fait nous
repousse progressivement serti dans
certaines capitales et puis ils ont
agrandi comme ça pour un bien pour biens
dispersés tout le monde façon il y avait
enfin voilà il ya eu un état d'urgence
décrété les alertes de couvre-feu
arrivée sur les sur nos téléphones
portables l'ambiance était en fait
limite plus apocalyptique allant à
l'extérieur du capitole qu à l intérieur
mais on est resté jusqu'au bout et les
gens sont beaucoup de gens sont restés
jusqu'au bout alors même que trump avait
fait un discours pour leur dire de
rentrer chez eux et c'est là c'est très
important c'était encore une fois les
gens qui étaient devant capital à ce
moment là
ont envoyé trump aux oubliettes ils ont
dit mais ils nous disent à eybens est
lui aussi c'est un traître est à filmer
justement un manifestant qui racontait
sa qui disait lui-même dit d'y aller
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait il prend sa
voiture il se barre et il était
parfaitement lucide cette personne il
disait trump tweed beaucoup mais fait
très peu c'est exactement ça et c'est ça
qui est fou c'est que même chez ces gens
là où on pense en regardant les images
voilà tous ces débats du front américain
ça il ya une extrême lucidité et trump
c'est pas celui qui a créé sa troupe a
été un prétexte peau mais la preuve
c'est le clan trump leur dit de rentrer
chez eux c'est pas des gens qui
obéissent c'est des gens encore une fois
qui légitiment pas massa sont en colère
le 6 janvier c'est l'expression d'une
d'une impunité d'un échec de la police
mais aussi d'une colère qui va bien bien
bien plus profondément dans ce pays et
on l'a vu pendant
avant géorgie dans cet état qui était
très divisée entre républicains et
démocrates qui va bien plus profond que
juste le mandat de donald trump et du
coup à la fin de la journée tu passes
combien de temps entre autre moment tu
sors du capitole et le monde part
je dirais 1h30 2h parce que du coup le
figaro m'a appelé
demain live on a faim on a fait un
direct on a les images d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs nous raconter un peu ce qui
s'est passé à ce moment là toi tu film
est juste en gros la la pelouse autour
ouais je suis mais la pelouse autour et
j'essayais en fait de garder le capital
dans le champ en filmant et dont le
cordon est arrivé je me suis retrouvé
sur constitution avenue ou une autre des
avenues qui s'éloignait du capital en
fait je marchais mais je continue à être
filmée par dessus mon épaule en fait je
ne savais pas que j'avais mais les
écouteurs que derrière moi il y avait
des preuves boys qui en fait penser que
je les filme et est donc en fait on s'en
rend compte sur le sur le live sauf moi
que en fait il était en train de
m'insulter de me dire de vous filmer
radio filmée radio filmée moi
j'entendais rien
et
mon photographe était voilée a essayé de
les contenir un peu mais bon à un moment
ils ont tapé dans mon téléphone ils ont
pris ils sont partis
tu es tu es ce que tu t'es senti en
danger pendant cette journée ont
finalement pas trop en fin de visite on
a vu que c'était tellement violent mais
tu disais que tu avais pas été pris pour
cible sinon je me suis pas senti en
danger mais je ne sais pas si c'est pour
cette gèrent très intelligent jeu
mais après je pense que comme tous les
journalistes ils se retrouvent dans une
situation comme ça et d'ailleurs comme
n'importe qui et dont les les
manifestants eux mêmes il ya une telle
montée d'adrénaline alors moi c'était
pour des différentes raisons c'est parce
que ben voila tu sais à un moment quand
même donc tout le monde va parler dit ah
bon
non mais encore une fois moi j'ai pas
été à l'endroit où les flics ont tiré
sur un jeu qui va bien j'aurais été là
ça peut être réagi autrement est très
bien et bien merci beaucoup vincent
d'avoir été là pour nous raconter ce que
tu as vécu il ya un an l'assaut du
capitole on le rappelle tout au long de
la journée il ya des cérémonies qui vous
qu'ils vont envoyer aux états unis
indique de joe biden un discours de
donald trump qui arrivera vers 23 heures
moi je vous donne rendez vous à 18
heures il y aura point de vue où on va
encore une fois de parler de cette
attaque du capitole un an après où en
sont les états unis et je vous dis à
bientôt sur figaro relève